es momento de hablar de economía quién
france24 toda la jornada del 28 de
agosto la tiene aquí la especialista
económica daniela blandón daniela
empezamos con la propuesta del impuesto
a las grandes fortunas en argentina que
llegó finalmente al congreso ahora muy
buenas noches lo saludó además con un
muy feliz cumpleaños hoy en media ciudad
y bueno pues le cuento que este proyecto
lo presentó el partido de gobierno
frente de todos justo hoy que se dio
otra noticia económica muy importante y
es que es la fecha final para sellar un
acuerdo con acreedores sobre la deuda de
argentina este proyecto del que
hablábamos consiste en que quienes hayan
tenido un patrimonio de 2,7 millones de
dólares o más con corte al 31 de
diciembre de 2019 pagarán por una única
vez un impuesto del 2 por ciento o más
dependiendo de cuántas sea su fortuna
esto también aplica para los bienes que
tengan en el exterior y se calcula que
cubrirá a unas 12 mil personas el
gobierno espera recaudar cerca de 4 mil
millones de dólares y el objetivo es
repartir los en partes iguales como
en la gráfica del 20% para compra de
equipos médicos otro 8% para subsidios a
pequeñas y medianas empresas y otro
porcentaje igual para educación otro 15%
será para atender a los barrios
populares y hay un 25% que va destinado
a programas de desarrollo de gas natural
muy bien daniela ahora hablemos de los
gremios de la industria aérea de américa
latina y es que se unieron para pedir la
pronta reapertura de los aeropuertos si
hablamos de la asociación internacional
del transporte aéreo el consejo
internacional de aeropuertos y la
asociación latinoamericana y del caribe
del transporte aéreo estos tres premios
o pues más grandes el mensaje para los
gobiernos fue muy claro reabra en
aeropuertos y minimicen las
restricciones eso porque la mayoría de
aeropuertos de américa latina cerró hace
cinco meses y varias aerolíneas ya han
quebrado los pocos aeropuertos que han
retomado operaciones como bahamas
república dominicana y ecuador están
exigiendo pruebas de 19 negativas para
el ingreso otros han establecido 42 por
eso la industria pide flexibilizar un
poco estas medidas
y reactivar un sector que espera
pérdidas por más de 484 mil millones de
dólares en apenas un año
daniela en chile el desempleo volvió a
marcar máximos históricos
las cifras dicen que en la pandemia se
han destruido 18 millones de empleos en
este país que tenía una de las cifras
más bajas de la región antes de la
llegada del cob y 19 que era del 75 por
ciento el más reciente dato dice que la
tasa de desocupación fue del 13,1 por
ciento en el trimestre móvil mayo-julio
un nuevo máximo histórico desde que
iniciaron los registros en 2010 si se
observa la tendencia vemos como ha
venido subiendo desde que inició la
pandemia primero se disparó al 11,2 por
ciento luego al 12,2 y ya volvió a
repuntar el dato particular es que a
diferencia de otros países la tasa de
desempleo en chile es mayor en los
hombres que en las mujeres a las
bueno vámonos con noticias empresariales
y es que coca-cola anunció una
reestructuración de su negocio a la en
esa reestructuración incluye entre otras
cosas el recorte de empleos y salidas
voluntarias un plan que aplica
inicialmente para 44 mil trabajadores en
eeuu canadá y puerto rico que hayan sido
contratados desde el 2017 en adelante
hace unas semanas les contábamos que la
pandemia había afectado el consumo de
coca-cola en el mundo y que el segundo
trimestre pues fue el peor en ventas
para la multinacional en 25 años con una
caída del 30 por ciento el negocio se ha
visto afectado porque como sabemos a la
gente ha permanecido en casa y no hay o
así inmensa restaurantes a los estadios
que es finalmente en donde más se
consume la cocacola de ahí que la
multinacional haya decidido reformular
su negocio y entregar indemnizaciones
que le costarán entre 350 millones y 500
millones de dólares vamos con los
indicadores económicos de este día bueno
2 y 2 hoy en wall street por un lado el
índice más importante el dow jones borró
todas las pérdidas de este año y por el
otro el estándar
500 renovó su recorte histórico por
tercer día consecutivo las bolsas
europeas bajaron con excepción de madrid
después de que se confirmaran las malas
cifras de economía europea y avances en
américa latina' lideradas por argentina
en donde cayó muy bien el final feliz de
las negociaciones para el canje de deuda
finalizamos con las cifradas del día son
los 6.500 millones de dólares
adicionales que el fondo monetario
internacional va a prestar a ecuador es
un plan de apoyo para superar la
pandemia del coronarios muy bien daniela
pues muchas gracias por este recorrido
económico y las felicitaciones muchas
gracias a ustedes por su compañía ya lo
sabe vea más mucho más en france 24
i